[音楽]
の
ん
ブービーいましたがこれほどチップスではなんてドッキリをパティっ以降すごいよ
patti patti パパですかんっ
出てくるというわけでございますこれ多分皆さんが想像してくれはりかいい力強いです
よ
グランにしてやってたらもうどうなるどうなるどうなる
[音楽]
本さ飛ぶんですよよくないですかぁーというで今回はでパサート分後の見たらさ
飛ばすだけなんじゃ特に今回はこれは何とかば改造してもっと意欲作しておわんちゃん
平均になるぞにが暗いと威力まであげようと思います
直営その1ひとまず一つの苦痛になる客さんの羽根を入れてみましょう
それがまだ最初の臓硯でしょう
晴れ
この2
car
th
ああああああ
指これはいかにマック利用してゆくの高いポテトチップスましーを作れるかという話で
ございますひとまずこれ一つに何個羽根が入るんだろう
1個は普通に入るですよ
もう一個ぐらい入ってる飲み込めいきます
しています
おおもう一個行けるんだよねこれ
skit うわーもう声も聞こえる
ポテ子なじゃん子入れから手品みたいなんだけどまぁ4つ入れカード
まだいけるぞこれでラストですから
[音楽]
いやバイプレイヤー腕がヤバイ本当につい作れやもう子だっけこれで蓋を閉じましょう
ねはい奇跡追記生
あー思う愛的にはこれなら家に鈴が入ってますこれじゃないべ多分めちゃくちゃ強いと
思うよじゃあ飛ばす実は果たしてこれ取れで力があるかをひとまず検証してみましょう
あげますよ
3普通はんっ
ああああああ
バッハ
うわああああああ
[音楽]
これは萌えるこれ頑張ってそこを首抜いたら2つ合体させたりできないから2つ合体さ
せたらそれにたくさん入ると思うのでなんとかそこらと貫通できればひょっとこ
[音楽]
シャアこれをくっつけてさらにたくさんの待ってこれたくさん参加させればいいんじゃ
ねぇ
これだけあればいいでしょう一つの筒に5個までば音が入ったね杏子5本くらいは晩年
が入る予定ですさてこいつら組み合わせていきましょう
これ超を入念にしなきゃだなー店が許されないからな
[音楽]
はぁっ
[拍手]
待てばねなんかが入って野蛮で忍者3個なんでもうず10分20これでいいと思います
4つ123の木仁川の入れくらいなんて言わからこそはぎ最良の馬名を入れています
tar
[音楽]
あああん
ええええええ
おっ
バーッ
[音楽]
うん
ああああああ
麻生でガーネッ腕4 a
ooooooooooooooooooooo oooo
6分
ゴーズ一つ一で起訴図1ぜひとストーンでドーン
ブーン強い子以降入ってでこちらがこのポテトチップと見せかけて何のファニーが
飛び出るドッキリの祖母つ折り13の詰め合わせ高いジョブ喪失になります
あんまりさわりだけない本当に食べに行くはマジでヤバいと思うんで
今回は早速これを使って切りを仕掛けたいと思いますでは行こう
うん
大決切るわねが完全伝えないといけないだろう
多分作品
なぜかなやってないと鉄空
鷹と鉄食べたり
全出演の年間たくさん食べたいから取って来てくれなきゃいけなかったわからん
よかったら食べてしてまず
たっ
部屋だけじゃないと思うんぜた美味しいから
ものが付いたでしょ強かったら食べていい
やってるよ
ええええええ
me
car
[音楽]
すごい言われるんだぞ
car watch